[Musik]
sie alle wollen auf und davon
die bündner sabrina und markus blum mit
tochter amira suchen das einfache leben
in der kanadischen wildnis vom zürcher
oberland nach kambodscha monika lehnert
und peter kruse erfüllen sich den traum
vom eigenen kleinen gasthaus carolin
schneider und daniel schafer aus dem
kanton bern ziehen mit ihren stücken
hunden nach schweden wo sie eine
campinganlage führen
[Musik]
es gibt drei frühstücks varianten nims
wiesbaden dem gasthaus von peter kruse
und monika lier hat heute wollen alle
schinken mit ein
[Musik]
das festhaus ist seit kurzem eröffnet
das schinken und ei frühstück wurde bis
heute noch nie bestellt
[Musik]
peter hat er in seinem leben schon so
manchen beruf er war zugbegleiter
sicherheitsmann buschauffeur nun kommen
hotelier wirt und koch hinzu doch das
kochen hat seine tücken
auch wenn es sich nur um spiegeln ein
schinken handelt
[Musik]
rückenwind
da verschlägt
im moment sind vornehmlich kambodschaner
im gasthaus einquartiert bereits in der
letzten folge gab es viel zu tun
guesthouse peter und monika loten zur
eröffnung von ihrem suisse gaben das
gewinner fest geschlossen sie mit einem
feuerwerk der guten hoffnung
frohe nachricht in kanada
[Musik]
trotz der schwangerschaft flog die
familie blumen noch tiefer in die
wildnis in der völlig auf gelegenen
blockhütte schafft es gerade noch
rechtzeitig einen ofen einzubauen
ein minus 20 grad in schweden gab es den
nachwuchs bereits zu bewundern
carolin schneider telefonierte zum
ersten mal in schwedisch während daniel
schafer und mit auswanderer rolf sich in
der küche amüsierten
der bau der zwingeranlage für die
schlittenhunde verzögerte sich immer
mehr
[Musik]
12 frühstücke hatte peter diesen morgen
verkaufen können
rekord die gäste sind noch immer mit dem
letzten bissen beschäftigt da ist monika
bereits unterwegs zu mir
sie hat beschwerden und braucht
behinderung für ihre geschwollenen beine
unten am strand kann sich monika 42
dollar massieren lassen
ich habe sehr viel raum fordere und
darum stets mit blut im ids und dir dass
ich ziemlich fürsorge schule wurde das
ganz extrem
und dann bin ich dabei
die dritte maschine war mit dem popo war
die stunde schäfer wer aber hat er mir
gesagt ich soll das mal ausprobieren und
sie macht das sehr gut
groß ausruhen kann sich monika nicht
denn die hauptsaison hat eben erst
begonnen
[Musik]
es gibt menschenfreundlichere orte als
den zugefrorenen chuck attersee in der
kanadischen einöde
doch hier hat die familie blum ihr
winterlager eingerichtet rauch steigt
aus dem neu installierten ofenrohr die
im sechsten monat schwangere sabrina ihr
mann markus soll die dreijährige tochter
amira haben die erste nacht in der hütte
hinter sich
[Musik]
zwischen mami und papi geschlafen und
extra - 2 sabrina und amira scheinen
also gut geschlafen zu haben
markus dagegen macht doch ihr einen
müden eindruck
kein wunder die nacht zuvor musste er ja
noch bis spät ein camino einbauen
nun macht markus sich bereit zum angeln
auf dem zugefrorenen see
[Musik]
aus diesem see hat markus schon einige
fische gezogen
allerdings war das im sommer vor
anderthalb jahren damals unternahm
markus zusammen mit frau und kind ein
langes pferde tracking zur kathedra
hütte es reifte die idee dass sie mit
solchen touren ihren lebensunterhalt
verdienen könnten
nun ist markus hier um solche trackings
vorzubereiten
aber auch um löcher ins eis zu graben
damit der fische fangen und seine
familie ernähren kann
mit zwei löchern verdoppelt sich die
chance dass ein fisch anbeißt
was ihre eltern auch an stellen mögen
amira ist fast immer dabei nun angelt
sie fleißig mit die minustemperaturen
lassen sie kalt
[Gelächter]
die blumen es wären wohl nicht
unglücklich wenn sich die realität an
youtube anpassen würde
[Musik]
vor einem halben jahr noch so klein wie
meerschweinchen sind auf den welten süße
hunde kids geworden
die schlittenhunde haben endlich eine
zone anlage und was für eine
die hütten sind eigentlich für menschen
konzipiert und vollumfänglich isoliert
[Musik]
daniel schafer hat für den innenausbau
sieben wochen geschuftet fast immer
alleine und dabei 24.000 schrauben
verarbeitet bei temperaturen bis zu
minus 40 grad
[Musik]
doch die eigentliche leidensgeschichte
verbirgt sich in der zeit vor baubeginn
daniel wurde während vier monaten
hingehalten er der bauunternehmer
endlich das fundament legte die hunde
mussten in dieser zeit im
transportanhänger und ein ketten
gehalten werden und litten zunehmend
darunter woche sicher so und die musik
sei ja shoppen zu drei dankt um
irgendwie eine andere lösung baut was
mit der hunger noch mal zurück geht
irgendwie noch immer ist der kapitän am
kolleg oder so und nach dem sport beruf
und westerburg macht ist steigend in die
ganze situation definitiv dann fühlen
sich die runde endlich wollen und mit
ihnen ihre besitzer
[Musik]
drei der prächtigen 700 häuser gehören
mit auswanderer rolf kaiser aber
ausgebaut hat sie daniel fast im
alleingang
rolf entpuppte sich als keine große
hilfe wegen der zwinger musste daniel
die renovation seiner eigenen bleibe
zurückstellen
carolin schneider ist unterwegs zur
täglichen putz runde trotz des winters
hat es ein paar gäste in den hütten
meist schweden die temporär in der
umgebung arbeiten die so genannten
studers zu reinigen ist teamarbeit auf
der campinganlage sancho baden
mittlerweile lebt auch rolf kaiser frau
sie war mit ihrer tochter lena hier oben
wobei rolf gegenwärtig meist abwesend
ist er hat sich entschlossen mit einem
job außerhalb der campinganlage das
familienbudget aufzubessern
daniel dagegen steckt seine ganze
energie in seine gaben beim putzen stößt
caroline in der küche auf eine
überraschung
neben dem herd steht ein bett da die
holzhütten zum teil nahe am see stehen
dürfen keine wasserleitungen verlegt
werden und es sind nur trocken wcs
eingebaut
herren scheinen die zeiten doch vor
einem halben jahr arbeitete caroline
noch in einem vip s auf der bank und
daniel schafer tat dienst bei der
polizei
[Musik]
wie sehr einem die arbeit gefällt die
man verrichtet manchmal ist es weniger
eine frage was man tut sondern für wen
man es tut
[Musik]
der strand von dialog will ist so gut
besucht wie selten im jahr
es sind fast alles kambodscha mehr wie
sie sich selber nennen denn es ist bond
das wasserfest eine der großen feiern in
kambodscha
viele touristen das bedeutet für monika
lier hat und peter kruse ein gutes
geschäft ihr gasthaus ist fast schon
voll als seine beitrag kambodschanische
familie eintrifft peter zeigt ihnen ein
zimmer mit zwei betten schläft alle hier
12345 peter lässt sich erweichen und
gibt den kambodschanern 5 dollar rabatt
zum missfallen von monika und die andere
und er gott jetzt noch 15
ich will in der ganzen stadt sind graz
immer mehr freien worten auf distanz sie
[Musik]
vor den gästen lässt sich monika nichts
anmerken aber peter erkennt monica serra
sofort
[Musik]
bis jetzt ist er nicht so spannend werde
der geburt fragt studie gesetzt sabrina
bluhm hat ihren geburtstermin in drei
monaten
und sie wäre dankbar wenn das kind nicht
vorher kommt beim fisch dagegen kann es
nicht schnell genug gehen wir ja ja ja
krass
[Gelächter]
von hermann und das mich nach und salz
und da wird
[Musik]
zurück in der blockhütte bereitet
sabrina den fisch auf einem petroleum
kocher zu fisch ist für die blums von
großer bedeutung damit sie genügend
eiweiß bekommen die hauptsächliche
nahrungsmittel die sie dabei haben sind
reismehl teigwaren zucker salz und öl
rund 100 kilogramm vorreiter haben sie
mit das muss mindestens reichen für drei
monate
[Musik]
blatnik cell ist ein kleines dorf mit
nicht mal 200 einwohnern
es ist die nächst gelegene ortschaft von
der campinganlage sun garden die man
selbst wiederum als kleines ziel und
bezeichnen könnte
15 häuser ein restaurant und eine paste
die schwedische version einer sauna
die hält die saugen auf verschont ich
gerade auf der verpasst du trifft daniel
einen schwedischen gast ich habe die
bastel eingeheizt kommt dass deutschland
nun ein schweiz
es ist wirklich ein schöner platz her
in ihre wohn baracke erledigt carolin
schneider büroarbeiten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
damals coffee zwei der hunde dürfen in
die gute stube so nah ihr haus hund und
die kleine areale die sich von einem
ärztlichen eingriff erholt die holzhütte
bietet viel weniger platz als die beiden
auswanderer noch in der schweiz hatten
dafür haben caroline und daniel viel
mehr raum für ihre beziehung ziemlich
immer kleiner berg unterwegs ich mir
weniger des small car hall und der
eltern natürlich draußen vor der hütte
erstrahlt ein magisches schauspiel
polarlichter am himmel zu sehen sie
entstehen wenn der sonnenwind auf die
erdatmosphäre trifft und luftmoleküle
zum leuchten anregt
[Musik]
premiere bei monika lier hat und peter
kruse
sie können sich nach dem stress einen
ausflug und überlasten das gasthaus zum
ersten mal ihren angestellten
haben sie von der möglichkeit gebrauch
also zur schule montag abgeschaltet
zu alten schlanken mann eine frau
o
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die beiden auswanderer steuern ein
touristenboot an
sie verbinden das angenehme mit dem
nützlichen und wollen wissen ob sie
diese schiffstour ihren gästen empfehlen
kann
nein
ja
nach einer stunde fahrt wird die
unbewohnte insel chorus sammlung
angesteuert bekannt für ihre
paradiesischen strände
[Musik]
[Applaus]
richtig schöne karibischen strand ich
das
[Applaus]
die wassertemperatur beträgt 28 grad
eine traumhaft der badewanne
[Musik]
alle weit weg so dass brasilien mittwoch
statt
also schau statt und wir es einfach
schön
haben sich zu dem anschlag
der muskauer
[Musik]
frühmorgens auf dem katiba sie markus
blum ist mit der kamera unterwegs
auf seinen reisen hat er mit der
fotografie begonnen
mittlerweile ist sie mehr als nur ein
hobby
er will damit geld verdienen markus
plant im nächsten winter mit einer
multimedia-show durch die schweiz zu
touren
eine weitere einnahmequelle für ihr
auswanderer abenteuer denn vom pferde
tracking allein lässt sich wohl nicht
leben einen elfmeter geschossen haben
auf englisch muss amira ist nicht das
erste kleine mädchen welches in dieser
hütte wohnt vor 18 jahren kam ein
französischer abenteurer mit frau und
tochter an den csa kathi dass sie und er
baute eigenhändig dieser blockhütte die
blues haben ein buch darüber gelesen und
wollten auch an diesen ort fasziniert
vom einfachen abenteuer leben
das braucht alles viele mussawi legte
nun und ins gleiche ist dass die
betreiber jetzt da alle dringlichkeiten
erledigt sind darf an ihrer das programm
bestimmen um ihrer die wunderbare
möglichkeit fast immer mit ihren eltern
zu sein
andererseits muss sie ihre gleichaltrige
freunde aus kommt ja dass schnell ein
begriff
bald wird amira ein geschwisterchen
haben mit dem sie dann spielen kann
[Musik]
carolin schneider hält zwei verschiedene
hunderassen die ausdauernden grönländer
und die kräftigen malamuten beide sind
die schlittenhunde
nun werden sie ihrer bestimmung
zugeführt
über ok
gaulin und ihr freund daniel verfolgen
nicht das ziel mit ihren hunden an
wettkämpfen teilzunehmen
sie würden ihren gästen der einst aber
gerne rundfahrten mit den hunden
anbieten
dafür brauchen sie eingespielte teams
caroline ist heute mit einem neuen
dreier gespann unterwegs denn es gab
einige veränderungen innerhalb des
rudels bei laufende fahrt kommt es zu
einer keilerei zwischen den drei hunden
thema und bruder bei einem frisch
zusammengewürfelten trio muss auch mit
einem streit gerechnet werden
daniel schafer kommt mit seinem zweier
gespannt zu hilfe
[Applaus]
colin hat einen der hunde aus dem
gespann genommen und an daniel übergeben
diese konstellation scheint besser zu
funktionieren
so kann auch karl in ihren schlittenhund
ausflug noch ein wenig genießen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das gar nicht
[Musik]
doch dann dieser dorf hält auch annina
kurzbold straße eine kehre zurück und
hat einen abzweig kurzen chelsea im stau
darüber zum staub
carolin und daniel fanden wegen der
campinganlage und dem zwinger bau kaum
mehr zeit und mit den hund hin zu
trainieren
es wird ein wenig dauern bis sie wieder
ein gut funktionierendes schlittenhund
gespann haben ausprobiert und herum mit
einer zwei grammies untereinander zwei
grammys vorangegangen was sich gut
trainiert die luft jetzt muss ich
einfach sukzessive
natürlich ist es gut gemacht in einem
jahr werden sie mehr möglichkeiten haben
passende 100 teams zusammenzustellen
denn dann kommt auch die
nachwuchsmannschaft in frage um vor den
schlitten gespannt zu werden
[Musik]
der kambodschanische kapitän steuert
sein schiff richtung heimathafen von der
paradiesische schönen strand atmosphäre
ist nur noch wenig übrig den kaufpreis
der tour inbegriffen gratis bier wenn
man es durch einen schnorchel trinkt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das kampftrinken ist beliebt bei den
jungen touristen vor allem aus dem
angelsächsischen raum
[Applaus]
[Musik]
monika und peter betrachten das ganze
aus der distanz
[Musik]
leider ist dann doch ein bier zu viel
den schnorchel runter geflossen
verantwortlich für die sauerei ist keine
der frauen sondern dieser junge mann das
erbrochene wird weggespielt auf die
untere etage
[Musik]
den ersten teil der schiffstour mit den
strandausflug werden monika und peter
ihren gästen uneingeschränkt empfehlen
können
die rückfahrt dagegen mit dem schnorchel
saufen trifft ihren geschmack weniger
danke sowie die jüngere generation
sofort die wohl zu sicher ein ipod-dock
im gasthaus scheint alles friedlich zu
sein
monika hat geschwollene beine vom
ausflug kann kaum mehr gehen
ihre gesundheitlichen probleme sind eine
wachsende belastung und es ist nicht
absehbar dass die arbeit im gasthaus
weniger wird und sich monika bald
schonen könnte
[Musik]
familie blum erkundet die umgebung der
takata hütte sie wollen die zeit nutzen
damit sie ihren gästen im sommer die
schönsten und überraschendsten plätze
zeigen können die blues haben gehört
dass es am fluss unten eine besonders
tiefe stelle gebe an der es von fischen
nur so wimmeln soll
gefunden haben sie sie bisher selber
noch nicht die temperaturen sind
gestiegen und der schnee feucht geworden
was als alltäglicher ausflug beginnt
zeigt zunehmend grenzen auf besonders
für sabrina die im sechsten monat
schwanger ist
prof
das gesetz larven mit besetzungen noch
mehr arbeit beschert
bist du dir stehen gut sich sonst ja
sowieso nicht zu können sich in fischen
ja ja es ist wissen dass israel der
schnellschüsse schwer und schwierig zum
lauf und wie sieht das ist neues macbook
und strenge dem schnee zum laufen
ich hatte wirklich ja ja ist alleine die
gasse schütze ist lockt jetzt ist alles
optimal verlaufen
die familie ist in der kanadischen
wildnis gefordert das wetter kippt und
der weg zurück zur hütte zieht sich nach
dem marsch ist nur noch an mir richtig
fröhlich
[Musik]
sabrina ist müde
der ausflug hat die schwangere sabrina
ans limit gebracht
[Musik]
ja deshalb dem schweren schnee ganz
recht auf der bucht und im umkreis von
200 kilometern liegt hier kein mensch
geschweige denn ein arzt selbst mit dem
flugzeug darüber dass zweieinhalb
stunden bis zum nächsten spital
großstadtdschungel der heilsarmee mehr
hilfe hilfe natürlicher schritt
und dann kommt das so gut dass rund alle
service muss nicht ja aber mit der angst
ständig kleber nein überhaupt nicht also
durch annett rahn etage scott hose
denn
[Musik]
es ist ruhig auf der campinganlage
sanchez garden die wintermonate sind
finanziell wenig einträglich obwohl die
steelers besser gebucht sind als
erwartet
das zu anlage gehörige restaurant läuft
dagegen nicht besonders gut
überraschend haben sich zwei personen
zum mittagessen eingefunden
es ist etwas kühler
entschuldigt bitte wir erwarteten keine
gäste und haben nicht richtig eingeheizt
ich hoffe es geht
carolin schneider selbst steht am herd
um das essen zuzubereiten
eine ungewohnte aufgabe für die
eigentlich mit auswanderer rolf kaiser
vorgesehen war
doch der gelernte koch hat keine zeit
einmal mehr hilft daniel schafer aus
diesmal als küchenhilfe golf geister
lässt sich nur kurz in der küche blicken
obwohl eigentlich geplant war dass er
als profi koch die verantwortung für das
restaurant trägt und das grundlegend neu
aufbaut
doch nun ist alles anders rolf hat es
vorgezogen in der küche eines hotels in
der nähe zu arbeiten
[Musik]
carolin muss viel mehr zeit im
restaurant verbringen als geplant wolfs
alleingang führt sogar zum zerwürfnis
zwischen den auswanderern doch dazu mehr
in der nächsten folge klar in schweden
auswanderer rolf plant von sancho garten
wegzuziehen
doch caroline daniel dürfen sich nichts
anmerken lassen denn sie veranstalten
ein großes mit sommerfest freude bei
familie blum
das baby ist da ein blick zurück auf
ihren winter aufenthalt
regenzeit in kambodscha die nebensaison
ist angebrochen
monika und väter nutzen die zeit um die
badezimmer renovieren zu lassen
ein veritabler scherbenhaufen
[Musik]
uli hoeneß